now yesterday I made the arguments that
there is no basis for objective morality
without God as an atheist you cannot
logically assert any kind of objective
moral code because you have denied God
and I argued that's the only thing left
for an atheist is moral relativism
that's really the only
option that is logically open to them
now I'm not gonna rehash that argument
you can go and listen to it or watch it
if you like my main objective was just
to knock down the idea that it's
possible for objective morality to exist
in a godless universe I spent 30 minutes
trying to do that so you can go and and
look at that I listen to that quite a
lot of feedback to that discussion much
of it ranging from negative to extremely
negative and now what I'd like to do is
I'd like to engage what appeared to be
the two most frequent criticisms of the
position that I expressed yesterday now
the first one I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time on I did want to mention it
though there were a lot of people who
insisted quite breathlessly that it is
possible for an atheist to do good
things and be a good person in fact as I
was told just because atheists believe
that there is no God doesn't mean that
they're gonna go off killing and raping
etc you don't need God to be a good
person I was told and to that argument
I say yes also who are you respond what
are you responding to and who are you
responding to of course atheists can be
moral of course atheists can do good
things
I never argued to the contrary I've
never heard any Christian argued to the
contrary honestly that's not an argument
that really exists it certainly wasn't
my argument I didn't argue that atheists
can't be good people I said that atheism
provides no rational basis for asserting
goodness and badness as objective
realities that's all that was my
argument
I'm not sure why so many atheists
struggle to understand this distinction
and it's kind of funny to me that
atheists like to impugn the intelligence
of believers while at the same time with
the whole invisible sky daddy and all
that kind of nonsense
while at the same time which which again
there is no Christian no Christian above
the age of 5 who actually believes that
God is in in the sky or that he's
magical so you know there's it's a it's
another another you know it's it's a
kind of really stupid straw man that I
see intent really that intelligent
atheists will use and it's beneath them
to get into that kind of stuff but they
do it and even here there is even among
intelligent atheists that appears to be
this inability to understand a really
basic distinction in nuance
so again I'm not saying that atheists
aren't good I'm saying that atheism that
atheism itself the belief system
provides no basis no rational basis for
asserting the objective nature of
morality that's my point
in fact my argument is actually the
opposite of what these critics seem to
understand my whole point and what I
said many times in that episode is that
atheists do act morally and they do
recognize moral goodness and they do
condemn moral evil which proves that
they do recognize the objective nature
of morality even if it contradicts their
worldview that was my point so a point I
made is that yes there are plenty of
good atheists who understand fact all of
them recognize moral goodness that was
my point that I was trying to make
now
you notice that atheists will tend to
have this confusion actually on the
other side too because many arguments
with atheists and my experience will
devolve into the atheist listing all of
the alleged crimes and atrocities
committed by religious people I cannot
tell you how many times I've had a
debate or an argument with an atheist
about the existence of God or something
along those lines and eventually they
start talking about the Crusades and the
Inquisition now the fact that they
reveal themselves to have very little
understanding of those historical
episodes is beside the point the real
point is that is that is that the
Crusades the Inquisition none of that
has anything to do with anything the
sins of the religion of religious people
are completely irrelevant to the
question of whether or not God exists I
was watching a debate with Christopher
Hitchens recently and he went on this
this whole tangent about the alleged
wickedness of Mother Teresa
now Hitchens was a was a brilliant guy
but this was an amazingly erroneous and
pointless rant as it obviously has no
bearing at all on the question of
whether God exists or not makes no
difference you can say whatever you want
about Mother Teresa
it's nothing to do with anything so it
seems that some atheists tend to think
that arguments about God are really a
contest over who between atheists and
religious people are the best people but
that is not the argument and that isn't
just not an argument that I've ever
heard a Christian make
I honestly I'd never ever heard a Chris
a Christian say that well Christians are
the best people in the world and if you
are a Christian then it prevents you
from doing bad things and if you're an
atheist then all you do is bad things
and you're out raping and killing I've
never heard that argument I honestly
have not once ever heard it expressed
from a Christian so we can put that to
the side second this is where I want to
spend the most time I heard from quite a
few people who said you know who openly
said that well morality is not objective
you know you're right
atheism provides no basis for objective
morality and that's because there is no
objective morality there's only what we
think is good or bad which is a
preference that depends on culture
evolution personality and so on so this
is moral relativism which might what I
was doing yesterday's I didn't really I
was trying to demonstrate that as an as
an eighth atheist the only thing really
opened to you logically is moral
relativism although I didn't really get
into trying to disprove moral relativism
so that's what I'm gonna try to do now
I'd like to explain why I think that
moral relativism is false why I believe
that morality is certainly objective
and I guess before we do that we have to
get in we I guess we have to define our
terms so on one hand you have moral
relativism which is the belief that
there is no underlying moral truth
there's no moral truth at all morality
is both subjective and relative in this
view so what is right and good depends
on my own perspective so that's
subjective and it depends on
circumstance so it's relative that's it
on the other hand
objective morality is the belief that
moral standards moral truths and moral
responsibilities exist independent of my
own preferences or opinions in other
words some actions are really good and
some are really bad and they remain good
or bad even if I think otherwise
even if everyone in the world thinks
otherwise the moral truth remains so
maybe instead of objective morality we
could call it actual morality I don't
know you know maybe that's a better term
but the point is that this belief holds
that immoral actions are actually
immoral that is per se immoral and moral
actions are actually moral that is per
se moral and just as we have actual
moral obligations to do certain things
and not do others and those obligations
exist
whether or not we recognize them or
whether or not we choose to follow them
or whether or not we like them so how do
I prove this well I'm not going to make
an exhaustive argument here but I will
in two points for consideration one I
think we have to start with you know my
first piece of evidence for objective
morality that I would present is your
own moral intuition I mean your own
understanding and my understanding which
is the same
and this is a weird argument I realized
because on one hand it's very weak in
that I can't provide tangible proof of
it because I'm telling you what's going
on in your own head
I can't prove and of course comes off
extremely presumptuous but on the other
hand it's a strong argument because as
you listen to it you know that what I'm
saying is true
so here's the point each person who says
that morality is not objective
in fact I'll personalize this you who
are listening to this right now if you
as an individual if you believe that
morality is relative if that's what you
claim to believe anyway then I'll talk
to you
so you say that Maura maybe you laugh at
the idea of objective Mars you know we
all have our own morality my morality is
not your morality so on and so forth yet
you say that yet I know that you know
that rape is wrong
you know that murder is wrong you know
that it's wrong to tell a lie
now maybe you've told lies in the past
but you knew it was wrong when you did
it and so you felt guilty for it
afterwards
and they're even and there are plenty of
people out there unfortunately who have
murdered and raped but unless they were
insane they knew it was wrong when they
did it
which which is why we can justify
putting them in prison
because they knew it was wrong and they
did it they didn't know what's wrong and
they did then they go to insane asylum
so you know it and when I say you know
it I mean you know it not that you've
decided it or that it's your preference
but that it's a thing it's a reality
that you know and that you recognize
okay so how do I know that you know it
well because if I murdered someone or if
I stole from someone you would not say
well that was you know that's that's
your opinion and that's your morality I
mean you know that that's what you
thought was right and so I'm not gonna
judge you know you you wouldn't do that
would you
you would condemn my actions and you
would condemn them with force and
intensity because I broke a code that
you think I ought to have followed which
means that you innately recognize the
code and you believe that I recognized
it which means that you believe it to be
objective that is not subject to opinion
another example you condemn the nots
even though your moral relativist you
still condemn the Nazi Holocaust and if
I launched a serious argument where I
said that the Nazis well you know the
Nazis they thought that what they were
doing was okay and I mean if they had
their reasons for it and hey let's not
force our morality on them if I if I
made that argument you would react
rightly with disgust and derision you
would mock me you would spit at me for
making that argument because again you
recognize that the Nazis broke a
universal code and that I in justifying
their behavior in denying that code
which in this context you see correctly
as a plainly absurd thing to do so even
though you claim to be moral relativist
if I'm a dame a consistent morally
relativistic argument in relation to the
Nazi Holocaust or rape you would laugh
at me you would laugh at your own
position if it was it was made to you in
reference to one of these things so that
is my first argument I know that
morality is objective because I can see
that it is and you can see that it is
and everyone can see that it is
and if something was truly subjective
then there is simply no way that we
would all have exactly the same sense of
it
that's the funny thing you know that all
of these moral relativists out there yet
none of them speak up to offer their
morally relativistic defenses of rape
Holocaust pedophilia well very few of
them do anyway as I said yesterday
Richard Dawkins did all for a bit of a
defense of pedophilia but even then it
was a half-hearted defense and and he's
certainly in the minority among
relativist and that's interesting isn't
it number two
and I think so I think it's a valid
point if I'm trying to disprove moral
relativism the fact that even moral
relativists don't believe in it I think
it's a relevant point you know number
two I think the objective nature of
morality can be seen and proven
historically and anthropologically if
morality were subjective if it were
decided by individuals and societies and
if it did not have a source outside of
ourselves then the moral systems of
every separate society
should be like their clothing choices or
the you know their fashion that is it
should be wildly different from place to
place and from era to era but that is
not what you find in fact if morality is
subjective
then I should I think I should be able
to find two things when I'm if I'm
looking around the world I'm looking
through a history of different
civilization
I should be able to find civilizations
that have no moral code whatsoever I
should be able to find civilizations
where nothing is considered right or
wrong and number two I should be able to
find civilizations that have something
close to the opposite of our own moral
code so civilizations where it's
considered absolutely right to lie
murder steal I should find civilizations
where cowardice is celebrated integrity
is derided given the number of
civilizations that have existed given
how separate they have often been
especially in the past I think it's
reasonable that an entirely subjective
thing should manifest itself in
extremely different ways opposite ways
that's what I that is what we find with
truly subjective things like fashion
okay so you can find societies where men
were pants societies where they were
skirts societies where people where
almost nothing societies where women
wear burqas societies where they wear
bikinis if morality is subjective that I
should find a situation as diverse and
contradictory as this but I don't
what I find as I look at civilizations
across the world in history is that
there is a unanimous agreement in
principle on a number of moral points
like it's wrong to lie it's wrong to
steal to murder it's good to be honest
to be humble to be courageous I find
basically the same sort of person
admired and the same sort of person
despised everywhere now it's true that
you find civilizations where terrible
evils are accepted in common place
obviously Nazi Germany every
slaveholding society is another example
but
you notice that even in cases where
terrible monstrous evils were accepted
they were still rationalized and
justified according to the same moral
code so murder was illegal under the
Nazis but they just claimed that
exterminating the Jews was not murder
now that claim was ridiculous obviously
but the fact remains that even they felt
the need to pay homage to this moral
code and to pretend that they were
following it why what was the point of
that and it's because in fact we
expected them to follow it to have
followed it's because we rejected the
idea that societies and individuals
invent their own morality that we could
justify putting the Nazi war criminals
on trial and then hanging them if
morality were really subjective we would
have no basis for condemning them
because that was their morality but we
were what we rejected that and said
there's only one you broke it you know
you broke it and now you face the
consequences I'm in slaveholding
countries like like our own prior to the
1860s
slavery was justified on the basis that
slaves weren't fully people what does
that mean
it means that even slaveholders
recognized that you shouldn't treat
people like that but they rationalized
that well these aren't people
a bad rationalization but the fact that
they made it at all is kind of
instructive isn't it
okay but you might say that well all of
these societies I've talked about so far
they they all interacted with each other
they came from the same human pool as it
were so they're in greet their agreement
on moral points is not very surprising
not because they're what because of this
interaction so fair enough okay
let's look at an example
should absolutely prove moral relativism
if moral relativism is true let's look
at the meeting of Indian civilizations
and Europeans so here we have people
that are entirely separated living in
isolation from one another who had never
come in contact never been exposed to
each other never exercised the slightest
influence on one another prior to their
meeting here we have a chance for
relativistic morality to really show
itself if morality is really relative
when you've got these two sides of the
world not come in contact with each
other and you have this completely
relative thing like called morality I
mean it should manifest itself in wildly
different ways
but that's not what you find incredibly
although the Indians and the Europeans
were extremely different in many ways
they still had the same fundamental
ideas about morality
so to prove my point I'll take the most
challenging example for my position we
can look at the Aztecs and the Spanish
now here we have two very very different
sets of people and the Aztecs practiced
human sacrifice on a massive scale yet
even they had basically the same kinds
of rules and laws and moral ideas as the
Spanish homicide rape perjury theft
robbery sedition incest public
drunkenness etc they were all condemned
both as legal and moral infractions now
yeah they ripped the hearts out of their
human sacrifices but they didn't
consider that murder
so again which doesn't make it okay
obviously now if you're a moral if
you're a moral relativist that does make
it okay that's the whole point of moral
relativist they didn't consider it to be
bad which means it wasn't as someone who
believes in objective morality I say
that that's not an excuse it was still
bad but the point is
again you see this this this thing this
invisible moral code
which appears to be the same everywhere
and which even the most evil
civilizations felt the need to work
around
so
that's why I think moral relativism is
false
because I see no evidence for it at all
all I see when I look
inside myself and when I look outward Li
to human societies our own other
societies civilization I look through
history all I see is evidence that
morality is objective it is a thing that
you it's not something you invent but
come up with it's a thing that you
recognize
which is why all of these civilizations
were came to the same recognition
although they all failed to follow it
in various different ways
some to worse degrees than others
but they all saw basically the same
thing
um a really relative thing a really
subjective thing should be various it
should be contradictory
especially when you see that it's
especially in cases where it's developed
where you have two systems that have
developed isolated from one another but
that's not the case with morality
which tells me that it is not in fact
relatives it is objective it is simply a
truth
that we all see
and we choose to follow or not
all right I'll leave it there Godspeed
everyone thanks for listening see you
tomorrow